hey what's going on guys this is Rob and
I need all of you guys to go to Joe
Rogan's Twitter account and just spam
his Twitter account and just say bring
comics explained on the podcast Joe
Rogan I want to be on the Joe Rogan
podcast it's like it's like the coolest
podcast ever and like I think it'd be so
awesome to be on there I'll teach you
everything about comics man I'll teach
you everything you wanna know about
comic books go over there and just spam
spam his Twitter account guys just spend
the hell out of the thing and then well
then we'll see what happens
either I make either I make an enemy out
of Joe Rogan which I really hope I don't
do or he's just like this man with a
magical voice I must bring him on to my
podcast because he sounds awesome and I
am okay so picking up with another
episode of of too powerful for Marvel
movies and this one I want to talk about
Sabretooth and I know this goes against
the conventional wisdom of the series
like that the basis idea the series that
like newer beings who are just too
powerful for Marvel movies like there
are their powers on too grand of a scale
to throw in tomorrow movies but
Sabretooth I feel like as a character
they couldn't do in Marvel movies and
here's the reason why Sabretooth well
there's two kinds of Sabretooth right
like you have classic Sabretooth and you
have new Sabretooth new Sabretooth as he
exists now in Marvel Comics he's a lot
more toned down I mean there's been a
lot of character development like
focusing on Sabretooth as a person like
he became a good guy for a little while
things like that uh-huh
you go back to Sabretooth of 1980s with
Chris Claremont no the guy was just an
under he was just a mindless killing
machine I mean just just mindless and
every since like all he wanted to do was
just kill and cause death and
destruction that's all he wanted to do
and he was very very very good at it the
way that character was done oh is a
whole different world
that's the thing to keep in mind guys
like this one of the things that I've
noticed I was in your think about this
the other day it's one of the things
that I've noticed having read Marvel
Comics for so long one of the things
we've noticed is that comic books have
got a lot more like g-rated so to speak
I mean now truly g-rated but like they
they become less dark and less like
violent over the years take for example
like the x-men after house of M the
x-men after the events of house of M it
was basically rebuilding the x-men
landscape and while you had darker
stories like X nicosia like even then
gate were still not that violent like
they were just kind of like okay so like
some things happen and some characters
get developed no no like the darkest you
really get during that point in time I
would say the darker should get after
house of them is when William Stryker
comes back and then blows up a busload
of mutant kids that's about as dark as
it gets but
that's that's let's Chris Claremont man
Chris Claremont did that all the time
God loves man kills one of the greatest
x-men stories of all time that
introduces William Stryker in the
purifiers people who believe that God
wants them to kill mutants this story
opens with the purifiers killing kids
they're begging for their lives they're
like no please don't you know like like
we don't know what we did wrong and they
were like like you were born that's what
you did wrong and then they just like
kill him and then magneto shows out and
he's like I'm so tired of this dude man
we really dicover God loves man kills
but like you saw that stuff all the time
now here's the here's the thing here's
why this worked so you look at
Sabretooth back during the 1980s really
1980s is like the most violent era of
his character so you look back at
Sabretooth during the 1980s and you say
okay here's a guy they were trying to
flesh out like they're trying to like
figure out how dark they could get away
with him being you look at someone like
the classic fights between Sabretooth
and Wolverine they were the stuff of
legend these are some of the greatest
fights ever in the history of comic
books it was dears it was they were just
ferocious I mean they would they what
they were just just cleaning flesh off
of each other I mean it was just
hardcore any was something you were
always excited to see right like
Wolverines like I'm here to take a break
from being on the x-men because you know
whatever and like I'm gonna go explore
some stuff or go travel around the world
or whatever and they just kind of sniff
it around he's like Sabretooth is here
it's like yep and you guys are fighting
out in the middle of nowhere which means
you guys could just have a knock-down
drag-out fight I mean it was it was
things like that
like take for example the mutant
massacre all right so Marvel had a story
called mutant Massacre and it was the
first big crossover event among all the
x-men titles and then Thor was thrown in
there for good measure and the idea was
that you had a villain named mr.
sinister who had previous or at least
gambit at previously contacted sinister
and said hey look I need you to
basically reduce my powers because I
can't control them energy is too
powerful so sinister does that and says
I will call on you for a favor later on
now fast forward and Chris Claremont
introduces the Morlocks and the Morlocks
were these mutants that existed
underground in I'm sorry in the sewers
of New York that were basically like
physically deformed they lived down
there because the physical appearance of
them would make them you know cast
doubts on the surface world and so they
took our refuge in New York sinister got
got wind of them and then he believed
they were experiments they were
basically things that he had created and
had gone awry and so he basically gets
he grabs gambit and says your job is to
grab Sabretooth and grab a whole bunch
of these guys and go to the Morlock
tunnels now damn it wasn't really told
what was gonna happen and he didn't know
what was gonna happen until he got there
and then once like all the Mafia all the
Marauders the the henchmen of sinister
started killing all the Morlocks gambit
bailed he's like I'm not having anything
to do with it and heat
I think he's saved like some warlock
girl and then just ran like he's like
this is way too much a visually the
x-men found out and they thought that he
was a part of it so they kicked him off
the team which created like this huge
schism between himself and rogue ah but
now like the other Marauders were there
and they're like we're doing this for a
job stay Ruth was doing it with a
pleasure he was just doing it because he
could he's like I just want to kill
people
you think that's pay me like I'll just
do it for the fun of doing it
sabertooths back then you throw him in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe who the
80s in the comics and you throw him in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe and you
say like in order to get to Wolverine
Sabretooth you have to kill all the
Avengers he'll tear the hilts harem
apart I mean he'll he'll rip them the
real written love pieces by a man would
stand a pretty good chance because his
Iron Man and he's got you know his
repulsion beams of stuff like that but
even even you know Sabretooth without a
man to him he'd still tear through Iron
Man now how long it would take him to
get to Iron Man would be kind of a tough
thing because I make it fly around he
can dodge you can bob and weave and so
on and so forth but spider-man he would
fall Captain America but he would be he
be handle with the greatest of ease it
would be an absolute bloodbath I mean he
was just here to the mall because he was
just like going to this animalistic
state if you one of those things were
it's like it's like why are they even
fighting him because they don't stand a
chance and that's that's kind of the
funny thing is because Sabretooth was
also a part of Team X I'm pretty sure so
he was part of that that black ops wet
work team with Wolverine er with Logan
before they were taken by weapons Plus
and thrown into the webinar program so
he does know how to operate with like
stealth and guile and stuff like that in
the old 80's comics he usually wouldn't
he would just go in it like a muted he
were just going guns blazing rip
everything apart and and they would be
like yep it's Sabretooth man killing
everything he finds it creates a crazy
situation because when you look at the
Marvel Cinematic Universe the characters
on a whole or a lot more toned down a
lot more ordered structured and
regimented and grounded in the real
world Doctor Strange uses man I mean
Doctor Strange would do fine because he
uses magic but like Doctor Strange uses
magic you know Tony Stark has is you
know repulsors and he's got his Iron Man
suit and so on you know black panther
has technology and vibranium spider-man
of course is spider-man but Captain
America can run really fast and punch
hard and throw a shield you know and
then you got like Black Widow and you've
got Hawkeye and so on and so forth but
again like they're basically kind of the
answer the question what if somebody was
just like a little more exceptional than
the average person right like Hawkeye is
just really really accurate Black Widow
seems like a really really good assassin
and like Captain America basically is
like a guy on steroids and like Iron
Man's super smart and Black Panther has
vibranium but like in and of themselves
there's nothing special about them the
only person who's even credible whole I
mean although take his banner twenty
into the whole can
be the end of end of sabre-toothed but
see the like we removed banner from the
equation we said okay banners not here
for whatever reason he's off doing
something I don't know trying to get
back together with Betty Ross even
though she friendzone like whatever the
case is like like he's he's off doing
his own thing so he's out of the picture
all right so that leaves everybody else
no way
like I mean especially if they're
separated now if they're all in like the
Avengers tower then sure they could
probably over overpower him just by like
sheer force of will but even then I
would say they probably have a chance
but if they were all individually
separated and it was like somebody went
to Victor Tree they went to like
Sabretooth and they said kill each one
of these guys and then I'll let you kill
Wolverine or something like that or even
if it was like Wolverine himself he was
like okay like for whatever reason
Wolverine feels like being a dick and
he's like you know what I'm not gonna
fight you Sabretooth until you kill all
the Avengers because whatever man we
need to make x-men movies we got to get
him out of the way so he can do it I
have no idea but whatever the line of
logic is Sabretooth goes on a warpath
and kills them all yeah I mean he would
invade stark tower he would kill
everyone in the building just to get to
Tony Stark and before 20 sark even knew
what was going on he be torn to pieces
like even with the Iron Man suit cuz
yeah I remember like like Sabretooth has
a healing factor plus adamantium so like
you're talking about him like popping
onto the scene so one he could heal from
any any amount of damage that's dealt by
by Iron Man and then two like he can
just tear through the Iron Man suit like
it was butter I mean he would rip
through it all so like Iron Man fall
like that in the blink of an eye now
Captain America would be the next to
fall like he'd he'd be the easiest
person to take out really but the only
the only difference here is Captain
America has a vibranium shield now
adamantium is stronger than vibranium if
it was Captain America Captain America's
shield from the comics did he would
stand a much better chance because he
has proto adamantium is basically iron
adamantium and vibranium kind of mixed
together kind of a not really but it's
like all those things kind of brought
together which create like this super
durable material which is technically I
guess the hardest material in the Marvel
Universe but I digress
the fact remains Captain America
wouldn't stand much of a chance but he
would he would get he'd get torn apart
especially because he can't um he can
run really fast but he can't run faster
than Sabretooth not a chance they were
truth would chase him down but he was
huge he would run through him that's why
I say everybody who's stark tower would
die so fast because he Richards would
move so quickly and he would he would
enjoy it Oh he'd be laughing and he'd be
loving at every step of the way after
that you go into spider-man spider-man
would fall pretty fast
the only thing the spider would have
over Sabretooth would be a spider since
but he couldn't really defeat classic
Sabre doll D could be classic he's not
spider-man in the MCU I mean spider-man
of the comics has done it before but
like in the MCU he would be
so really it would just come down to
Peter Parker just fleeing for his life
that's all it would be him just running
as fast as he can at the end of the day
it would all boil down to dr. strange
like binding Sabretooth or like wiping
his mind or something like that
something you know something on those
lines
I mean Black Widow would fall Hawkeye
would fall I mean they would all die
it's mindless ferocity which is
something that we've never seen in the
model cinematic universe even Thanos as
hardcore as he was was not mindlessly
ferocious like everything needs to be in
balance because you know like I'm Thanos
and I have I have this Jimmy's idea I'm
gonna wipe out half the life in the
universe why because the universe is
overpopulated
well hey Thanos I have a question what
happens when like everything goes back
to normal and like the other half of the
universe it lifts just like procreate
and then like we're right back where we
were before you're not really fixing
anything ah dusted well you know I mean
it's like this like god famous was an
idiot in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
and unless the fact remains here like
Thanos was ordered structured regimented
right Gamora ordered structured
regimented everything is like that it's
it's grounded to make it easier and more
tangible for us as viewers to understand
really for the casual movie goer to
understand you take all that order and
structure and then you throw chaos in
there and watch what happens
it'd be a bull in a china shop which I
think will be cool to see that's why
when they do x-men movies I want to see
classic like 1980s Chris Claremont
Sabretooth just violent ferocious
killing everything in his path laughing
all the while taking enjoyment I mean
even Liev Schreiber's like Sabretooth
from from like the The Wolverine Origins
movie that's not 1980s Sabretooth that's
still restrained is a whole different
beast like I mean it's like you'd have
to go back and read 1980 Sabretooth to
really see how violent he was it was
insane I mean he was just like I mean
there was there was one fight where he
and Wolverine fought each other like
Sabretooth just like - is Wolverine
stomach and just like spills his guts
everywhere it's stuff like that like it
was just it was just insane knock-down
drag-out fight they were amazing fights
but nonetheless saber-tooth doesn't have
like a huge ad Lee powerful right he's
not like Franklin Richards he's not
molecule man or anybody like that but
because of the fact that he's so chaotic
because of the fact that he's such a
mindless killing machine because of the
fact that like he won't stop until
someone like Wolverine makes him stop
Hewitt he would tear buddy to shreds
like I mean that they wouldn't stand a
chance so I think it's kind of a cool
concept I think it's a cool idea
grab Sabretooth roam in the MCU and just
watch how it all unfolds but with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end if you are new here -
comments explained make sure you guys at
the sub button to become part of the Rob
core if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like
yeah I will catch you all later purse
[Music]